nouveau dans le sud du Québec.
Et ça crée des frictions.
- Forêts, tourisme,
villégiature, la MRC de Papineau
dans l'Outaouais est surnommée
le pays de l'or vert. Devra-t-on
bientôt y ajouter l'or gris?
À 3 km de l'immense lac Simon
et juste à côté du lac Doré,
une mine de graphite pourrait
voir le jour dans cinq ans.
La compagnie canadienne Lomiko
Metals y détient des droits
d'exploration sur une bande de
15 km. Ce qu'on appelle un claim
minier.
SIRI GENIK, dir., Développement
durable et comm.Lomiko Metals
- On a eu, je vous dirais,
de la chance d'avoir un actif
qui, avec le forage, a démontré
qu'il y avait une valeur de
graphite de qualité supérieure.
- Encore bien des étapes sont
à franchir, mais l'entreprise
est optimiste. Le graphite
est un minéral utilisé dans
l'électrification des transports
et Québec proclame maintenant
vouloir devenir la batterie
du nord-est américain.
JONATAN JULIEN, ministre Énergie
et Ressources naturelles, Québec
- Toute la chaîne des minéraux
critiques et stratégiques,
on veut l'avoir au Québec pour
se positionner comme un leader.
- On n'est plus dans l'ère
de la guerre du pétrole là, on
rentre dans l'ère de la guerre
des minéraux stratégiques.
- Résident du secteur,
Louis St-Hilaire milite depuis
deux ans contre le projet.
LOUIS ST-HILAIRE, Regroupement
protection lacs, Petite-Nation
- Installer ça dans des lieux
comme ici, pour moi, au début,
mais pour tout le monde à qui on
en a parlé c'est inacceptable.
C'est comme installer un parc
industriel en pleine nature.
- Il s'inquiète aussi
de la multiplication des claims
miniers dans les zones
de villégiature.
- Tout le tour ici et dans les
Laurentides et dans Lanaudière,
c'est des terres de la Couronne
ou à peu près. Puis ça,
n'importe qui peut réclamer
ça pour faire du forage
- on constate une explosion
des claims miniers dans certains
secteurs du Québec, surtout dans
le sud.
- Ugo Lapointe a cofondé la
coalition "Pour que le Québec
ait meilleure mine". Le sud de
la province, dit-il, abonde de
minéraux stratégiques pour
l'électrification des transports
UGO LAPOINTE, cofondé "Pour que
le Québec ait meilleure mine"
- 2019 par exemple, selon les
chiffres du ministère des mines,
c'est l'année record
des investissements pour
le lithium et le graphite
au Québec là, en terme
d'exploration. Donc, les gens
commencent à voir ces foreuses
là, les gens commencent à voir
les hélicoptères avec
les machines géophysiques voler
au-dessus de leurs milieux
et s'inquiètent et on va
en voir de plus en plus.
- Sur cette carte de
l'Outaouais, des Laurentides et
de Lanaudière, toutes les zones
rouges représentent des claims
miniers. Et beaucoup concernent
le graphite. En Outaouais, leur
nombre n'a pas changé. De 2015
à 2020, il y en avait 81.
Mais dans les Laurentides,
le nombre de claims de graphite
est passé de 88 à 171 en 5 ans.
Et dans Lanaudière, il est passé
de 129 à 301. C'est d'ailleurs
dans cette région que se trouve
le projet le plus avancé ; celui
de "Nouveau Monde Graphite"
à Saint-Michel des Saints.
Québec lui a donné son aval ;
la coupe forestière est
commencée et la future mine
aura une longueur de 2,6 km.
JEAN-GUY GALIPEAU, maire
d'Amherst
- Il n'y a pas tellement
de territoire dans les
Laurentides qui pourraient être
susceptibles à l'implantation
d'une mine à cause de notre
vocation de villégiature.
- Maire d'Amherst au sud-ouest
de Mont-Tremblant, Jean-Guy
Galipeau rappelle qu'un claim
de graphite existe déjà dans
sa municipalité, mais il est
inactif pour l'instant.
- Si c'était exploité de façon
logique, c'est-à-dire en respect
de l'environnement, puis tout
ça, je pense qu'on serait pas
contre ça là, de créer de
l'emploi. Mais, parce qu'on a un
grand territoire Amherst
de 249 km carré, mais ce n'est
pas le cas pour l'ensemble
de la MRC des Laurentides.
Jonatan Julien, ministre de
l'Énergie et des Ressources
naturelles, Québec.
- Il y a des dizaines de
municipalités qui se mobilisent
- Préfet de la MRC de Papineau,
Benoît Lauzon voudrait pouvoir
interdire les claims miniers dès
que des résidences se trouvent
aux abords d'un lac, ce qu'il ne
peut pas faire actuellement.
BENOIT LAUZON
préfet de la MRC de Papineauon
- On n'est pas capables
de bien protéger nos lacs
et nos rivières. Quand on
travaille avec les critères
du gouvernement, présentement,
on est capables de protéger
à peu près 59 % de notre
territoire. Puis ce qu'on
demande au gouvernement, quand
on a déposé les demandes
au gouvernement, il y avait 11 %
de plus qu'on demandait
qui était ces lacs-là.
- 90 résidences se trouvent
autour du Lac Doré où Lomiko
Metals souhaite implanter
son projet.
- Le claim est existant fait
qu'on peut pas arrêter un claim
qui est existant, fait qu'on va
travailler avec ces gens là.
- On a décidé d'anticiper
sur les préoccupations,
de comprendre où on était pour
s'assurer qu'on ne dérange pas
ou qu'on ait une empreinte
absolument minimale au niveau
de l'eau, de tout ce qui est
milieux humides, même visuel,
même au niveau du bruit.
- Il pourrait se coller direct
sur le lac, il n'y a même pas de
limitation parce qu'il n'y a pas
de construction sur ce côté là!
- Louis St-Hilaire demeure
inquiet même si ses démarches
ont convaincu plusieurs élus
régionaux de monter
aux barricades.
- Auand on arrive à Québec,
ça bloque, ça bloque carré,
carré. C'est qu'il n'y a aucun
intérêt à changer les régles
pour définir où on peut mettre
des mines. Il n'y en a aucun,
aucun. Aucune volonté politique.
- Il craint que devenir
la batterie du nord-est
américain soit un gros prix
à payer pour bien des résidents
du sud du Québec.
Ici Jean-Sébastien Cloutier,
Radio-Canada, Lac-Simon.